(Audio description) A white man
with glasses sits at a marble table
next to a plate of sliced pears.
Hi, I'm Andrew Leland.
I'm blind.
And this is a TED Talk about blindness,
which is confusing for me and for you
because just by watching me right now,
you can probably tell I'm not blind.
For example, I can tell
that on this plate right here,
there are five slices of pear
arranged in a smiley face.
Or that that --
(AD) A framed photo
hangs on the wall behind him.
AL: Is a photograph of a very sad hippo.
So you might be wondering,
if I can see all that,
why am I talking about blindness?
OK, so I'm going blind.
I don't know exactly when.
As a teenager, I was diagnosed
with retinitis pigmentosa, or RP,
which is a degenerative retinal condition.
In my teens and early 20s,
I only noticed it at night.
Then in my early 30s, my peripheral
vision started to deteriorate.
Right now I have central vision,
but I'm seeing the world
through a pretty narrow porthole.
So even though I can see these pears
and that hippo, I'm legally blind.
I have severe tunnel vision,
but it doesn't look like a tunnel
because your brain adapts
really quickly to whatever you see.
Like if the frame
of the movie you're watching
starts to shrink to a much smaller size,
at first you'll be annoyed.
"This sucks," you might say to yourself,
"I don't like watching this movie
on this tiny screen."
Then your complaints
will soften and disappear,
and your brain will adapt
to the new normal.
Like the first time you watch
a movie on your cell phone,
it will be annoyingly small at first,
and then you just get used to it.
So every time I lose
another chunk of vision,
at first I feel super extra blind,
sometimes scared or claustrophobic.
My world is shrinking.
But then a week will go by,
I get used to it,
I don't feel so blind anymore.
This experience of super gradual
vision loss has given me time
to think about what blindness is,
which might seem like an obvious question.
Blindness is the absence of sight,
but it's actually
more complicated than that.
Trying to define blindness
can start to feel paradoxical.
There's a paradox that's useful
in thinking about blindness.
It's called the paradox of the heap.
Let's say you have a heap of something,
like sand or marbles or goji berries.
Now imagine I take a single little
goji berry off of the heap.
Is it still a heap?
OK, what if I remove a second
tiny little goji berry from the heap?
Obviously that is still a heap also.
But, the ancient Greek
philosopher wondered,
at what point is it no longer a heap?
How many goji berries do I have to remove?
Is it still a heap
when there's only ten left?
Five?
Vision works this way too.
How much vision do I need to lose
before I can legitimately
call myself blind?
I saw this photo online the other day.
(AD) In the photo,
a Black woman holds a white cane
and looks at a cell phone.
AL: The image circulated with a caption,
"If you can see what's wrong,
say 'I see it.'"
Can you see what's wrong with this photo?
The answer that the people
sharing the photo had
is that the woman can't be blind.
If she is, why is she
looking at her phone?
Blind people don't look at things.
The caption wants you to remember:
blind people don’t see.
And if she can see,
what's she doing with that long white cane
that signals to the world
that she's blind?
Maybe she's trying to get sympathy
that she doesn't deserve
or trying to trick us somehow.
So how blind you have to be to be blind?
How much vision do you have to remove
from the heap of sight
before it becomes blindness?
People love binaries,
especially people on the internet,
which is a place that's not always
very friendly to ambiguity.
This photo was shared
more than 33,000 times,
and I think it went viral
exactly because of its ambiguity.
It illuminates a weird,
paradoxical truth about blindness.
Blind people can see.
I don't mean this in the way
that people mean it
when they talk about Daniel Kish.
Kish makes clicking sounds with his mouth
that he uses to navigate his environment
the way a bat uses sonar.
Brain scans show that when Kish navigates
his environment this way,
using his DIY sonar,
his visual cortex lights up.
That's amazing.
But the point I'm making is much simpler.
On the one hand, blindness is a binary.
You're either blind or you're not.
But on the other hand,
blindness is a spectrum.
There are different degrees of blindness
and different styles.
Some people have the inverse
of what I've got.
They only see through their peripheral
vision with nothing in the center.
Other blind people see the world
as though their glasses
have been smeared with Vaseline
or their head's been wrapped
several times in saran wrap
or like they're looking through
a thick, broken fishbowl.
Only very few blind people
see nothing at all, total darkness.
As I lose my sight,
I experienced this degeneration
the way you might expect:
as a loss.
In the meantime,
I feel privileged to still be able to see
things like sunsets or tree frogs
or celebrity breakfasts on Instagram.
There's another paradox
lurking around here.
If blindness is a spectrum,
could it also include somebody
who's not actually blind?
The paradox works the other way.
How much sight do you have to add
before someone's no longer blind?
At a certain point, we do have to agree
that someone's not blind,
even if they don't see very well.
I do think it's important
to reserve blindness for people
who don't have the luxury
of correcting their vision,
who need assistive technology to do things
like read print or walk around.
On the other hand, separating out
blindness like this
can lead people to view the blind
as strange or mysterious or off-putting.
And that can lead to fear and sometimes
damaging misconceptions and stereotypes,
like the idea that blind
people are psychic,
which some people actually believe,
or that they have super hearing.
(AD) Words appear:
Superpowers for the blind.
The brain rewires itself
to boost the remaining senses.
AL: Or more destructively,
that they can't go to a normal school
or hold a normal job
or travel on their own.
So the next time you see
a blind person do something
that you think only
a sighted person should do,
like making eye contact with you
or watching a movie,
or standing at a bus stop
checking their phone,
remember, it might be possible
to see even if you're blind.